-I also wanted to play you
in a game of basketball.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
MVP -- they're talking about me.
There's no way I could obviously
beat you in basketball,
but how about
video-game basketball?
How about "NBA Jam"?
-I'm in. Let's do it.
Let's do it.
I'm in for that.
-Let's do it right now.
Let's go.
Let's play some "NBA Jam."
Let's do this. Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
All right.
-Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
-Now, I play this game --
-How --
-What?
-You play it what? All the time?
-Well, no, once, twice a year,
something like that.
But I love this game.
Yeah, this is
"NBA Jam: On Fire Edition."
I played so much
that I unlocked some legends.
So, I'm Larry Bird.
I got to be Larry bird.
-That's fine.
You're Larry Bird.
-I'm Larry Bird.
-And I'm Russell Westbrook.
-There you go, man.
All right, so, here's the deal.
We have one quarter, right?
It's two minutes, and that's it.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
You down?
-Good luck.
-Who's your teammate,
by the way?
Mine's Kevin Garnett.
-Mine's Rumble, baby.
-The mascot?
-Yeah.
-All right. Ready for this?
Here we go.
-Let's do it.
-Here we go.
-Let's go, Rumble!
-Go! Come on, Garnett!
-Oklahoma City wins the tip.
-Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh!
-What?!
-Bird...
He shoots!
-Oh, gimme that.
Outta here, Larry.
-Shoots from midrange!
-Good. Larry scored 2.
Oh, my God. You already
swatted me. I'm nervous.
-To Westbrook.
-Yeah! Sit down!
Sit down, dude!
Give me the ball!
Pass it! Dunk it!
No, Larry!
[ Laughter ]
Yeah!
-Westbrook...
-Ohh! Yes!
Ooh, what's this?
Oh, it's a 3-pointer.
Ooh! What's up, dude?
Dude, you're getting
a Bird bath right now, dude!
What's up?!
-Lays it up.
-All right. All right.
All right.
-We got a minute.
-7-4. Here we go.
-Passes it.
Oh, homey don't play that.
-Ohh!
-Oh, get up. Give me that.
-Getting physical!
-No-look. I'm not looking.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Here's Westbrook!
-Oh. It's all right.
7-10. 7-10. Here we go.
-Gimme that!
-Get that mascot out of here!
Ohh!
-Give me that!
-Aah!
-To Westbrook!
-Ohh! [ Laughs ]
-Three!
-Are you running the clock out?
What are you doing?
Ohh!
Tie game! Tie game! Tie game!
♪♪
-With the bomb from long range!
-Whoo! [ Laughs ]
Hurry up. 5 seconds left.
-Moving the ball nicely.
[ Buzzer ]
-Yes! The winner!
-The Celtics win the game!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness!
-It's a glitch. It's a glitch.
-Russell Westbrook, everybody.
His new book, "Style Drivers,"
is available now.